>> IN THE CASE OF THE OPPONENT.
ANY INTEREST BOTHERED TO LEARN.
ANY KIND OF INCLINATION TOWARDS
PUBLIC SERVICE OR ELTING ALTHIN
PEOPLE IN ANY WAY.
AT LEAST WE DON'T REALLY KNOW
ABOUT IT, AND THAT DOES MAKE YO
SUSPECT.
HE IS A CELEBRITY WHO WANTS TO
BE A POLITICIAN.
HE WAS A POLITICIAN BUT VOTED
PRESIDENT MORE OFTEN THAN NOT I
THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
HERE IS THE REPUBLICAN SENATOR
CANDIDATE FROM.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER IT YOU MIGHT
HAVE BEEN ON THE PRESIDENTS
PHYSICAL FITNESS PROGRAM, YOU
WERE ON THAT BOARD IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN AND IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN
, FOR HOW MANY YEARS
HAVE YOU BEEN RUNNING FITNESS
CAMPS FOR CHILDREN AND YOU MIGH
WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
YOUR OTHER VOLUNTEERING WORK AN
OTHER THINGS YOU'VE DONE THAT
APPARENTLY BARACK OBAMA KNOWS
NOTHING ABOUT.
>> HE DOESN'T CARE TO KNOW ABOU
IT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THEY WILL
SAY AND DO ANYTHING TO WIN THIS
EVE AT THEIR NOT GOING TO WIN I
FOR ME THIS SEAT IS TOO
IMPORTANT AND I WANT THE GEORGI
PEOPLE TO KNOW RIGHT NOW THEY
ARE DOING WHATEVER THEY CAN AND
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH ME TO
WIN THAT SEAT SO THEY'RE GOING
TO TRY TO PUT ME DOWN BUT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO WIN.
THEY DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THE CRIM
DID THEY, RIGHT NOW THE CRIME I
UP.
THEY DIDN'T TALK ABOUT INFLATION
.
THEY DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THAT, AN
THE REASON WHY IS BECAUSE
SENATOR WARNOCK.
SENATOR WARNOCK WAS THE FACTOR
IN MANY OF THESE THINGS.
HE VOTED FOR MEN AND WOMEN
SPORTS, WHAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THAT.
THERE GOING TO HAVE TO COME FRO
THROUGH ME, THEY ARE COMING FOR
YOU TOMORROW BUT THEY'RE NOT
GOING.
>> TO YOU BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
GO THROUGH ME FIRST.
TO KEEP ONE THING THEY HAVE IN
COMMON AS THEY BOTH PRAISED THE
REVEREND JEREMIAH WRIGHT'S.
I GOT A PICTURE OF OBAMA AND
LOUIS FARRAKHAN, HE HAS PRAISED
I DON'T EVEN THINK OBAMA DID
THIS, BUT OBAMA PRAISED VITO
CASTRO.
>> YOU SEE WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
ABORTION, HE BELIEVES A BABY
THAT SURVIVES ABORTION, HE WANT
TO DENY THAT BABY MEDICAL CARE.
MAY HAVE SOMEONE LIKE LIKE
SENATOR WARNOCK REPRESENTED THE
GOOD PEOPLE OF GEORGIA BECAUSE
AM GEORGIA BORN, GEORGIA.
I AM NOT GOING TO LET THEM
CONTINUE TO PUT THE GEORGIA
PEOPLE DOWN THROUGH THEIR RACIS
THINGS THAT THEY SAY ABOUT THE
GEORGIA PEOPLE IS NOT TRUE.
I WANT PEOPLE TO GET OUT AND
VOTE.
THEY GO TO WASHINGTON TO
REPRESENT US, BUT THEY ONLY
REPRESENT ONE SIDE, IT'S GOING
TO BE THE BLIND SIDE, I
REPRESENT EVERYBODY.
WHITE, YELLOW, GREEN, EVERYBODY
FROM GEORGE UPRIGHT NOT GOING T
LET REVEREND WARNOCK AND I'M NO
GOING TO LET X PRESIDENT OBAMA
HURT MY FAMILY.
THE THUGS AND GANGSTERS, IS THA
THE GUY YOU ARE RUNNING AGAINST?
>> THAT IS THE GUY RUNNING
AGAINST FRED THE GUY THAT HAS
ALL THESE THINGS.
HE HIDES BEHIND THESE COURT
RECORDS.
I TOOK HIM TO SCHOOL, HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE ONE TO TEACH
ME, BUT I TAUGHT HIM.
PEOPLE SOUGHT THAT HE WAS NOT
THE PERSON HE CLAIMED TO BE.
HE WAS A WOLF IN SHEEP'S
CLOTHING I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
.
HE REPRESENTS JOE BIDEN.
TO HAVE PRESIDENT OBAMA COME
HERE, HE TOLD US TO VOTE FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
DO YOU THINK WE CAN TAKE SIX
MORE YEARS OF THIS?
WE CAN'T.
WE CAN'T TAKE SIX MORE YEARS OF
THAT BECAUSE THEY WOULD DESTROY
THIS COUNTRY.
I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT THEY WON'
TALK ABOUT THE CRIME, THEY WANT
TALK ABOUT THIS OPEN BORDER.
THEY WANT TALK ABOUT PEOPLE OUT
IN THE STREETS ARE TALKING ABOUT
, THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT.
THEY WANT TO TRY SMEAR ME.
STICKS AND STONES MAY BREAK MY
BONES, BUT WORDS ARE NEVER GOIN
TO HURT ME.
I AM GOING TO FIGHT FOR THE SEA
BECAUSE IT'S TOO IMPORTANT.
>> CLEARLY, CHECKS YOU WERE HAS
YOU ON HIS MIND.
I THINK THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
YOU, HERSCHE